with just eleven days before voters head
to the polls for the midterms we're
taking a closer look at election
security in our series issues that
matter
earlier this year Congress approved 380
million dollars to help safeguard voting
systems against cyber attacks the
threats of hacking and continued foreign
interference continue to be major
concerns Democratic Senator Mark Warner
of Virginia is a leading voice on
election security
he is the vice chair of the Senate
Select Committee on Intelligence
senator good morning thank you so much
for joining us we've learned that the US
Cyber Command just recently launched an
operation to combat Russian interference
in our elections and this spreading of
misinformation that they're involved in
how effective do you think that
operation will be the more I want to get
to election security but I want first
express some level of relief at this
point that's so far this act of terror
these bombs being sent around the
country have not caused any harm
personal harm yet I've been very
concerned about the president's tone
not being willing to call out and call
up for that matter the two former
presidents who were going to be victims
of this kind of attack and one of the
things about this president is I don't
think he understands that words matter I
mean I was governor of Virginia when we
had the sniper incidents years ago and
how leaders respond in these moments of
crisis in reassuring the public and
trying to bring us together clearly not
the way you because you're on the
Intelligence Committee you get a lot of
briefing are you convinced that they
will find this culprit who simply I
believe we will find this culprit but I
think in a time when our political
debate has gotten so rough and frankly
when the president at times calls out
and impugns the integrity of the FBI
impugns the integrity of the Justice
Department I believe in many ways he
basically this is a assault on rule of
law and that brings us to the election
security piece but before you move on to
that a lot of people feel the way you do
senator that words matter
why don't a group of you all get
together and just confront him and say
you know mr. president this is not
helping you've got to stop it so many
people come on this program and say
exactly what you're saying this is
this is bad Oh what are we gonna do it's
very tit for tat but I know there are
people that feel a lot of people that
feel the way you do in very powerful
positions why don't a group of you just
confront him and say stop it well I
think as we've seen from his tweets
overnight Donald Trump thinks all of
this is simply about him and what I hope
to have hoped along the way would be
that the next outrage would finally make
many of my Republican colleagues step up
now privately they have expressed these
concerns this may be the moment but
because again we've got 10 pipe bombs an
act of terror and yet the president is
out instead blaming the media as opposed
to supporting the FBI to make sure we
find this culprit so back to the
election secure election security what
is the US Cyber Command doing to combat
what is the spread of false information
by foreign governments let's let's break
that into two categories first of all we
do know that the Russians in 2016
massively intervened in our elections in
21 it's 20 more than 21 States
misinformation cyber attacks and that's
bipartisan all come out of our Senate
Intelligence Committee and in a normal
world because of our elections that are
spread between federal state and local a
normal white house would have appointed
someone in charge of election security
to coordinate these kind of activities
to push back instead this White House
not only didn't appoint anybody on
election security but they actually
eliminated the cybersecurity position at
the White House no attacks against him I
spoke at the director of the FBI the FBI
is looking into this what I'm asking you
is what and give me based on what you
know what are we doing to push back
against this insult let me let me finish
because the FBI they're working very
hard but what they have not had is a
level of coordination across government
so we have improved security and almost
all of the polling positions but there's
three areas that were vulnerable one the
voter files where your names go to make
sure that when you show up your precinct
you're in the right precinct there are
three companies that control 95% of all
our voter files they have not had
independent audits or independent review
at the voter stations where you actually
vote DHS Department of Homeland Security
has improved security but because we've
not been able to pass bipartisan
election security legislation we put
money out there but what we haven't done
is make sure that every state has a
paper trail to be able to audit after
the fact in case those systems were
broken into that's crazy in my mind in
Virginia I made sure we updated all our
machines in the third area is where you
tabulate the votes I think in terms of
voter security at the polling station
and the tabulation we've gotten better I
have huge concerns about the issue of
these three companies that control the
voter files people are showing up and
being told you're not at the right
polling station but what we need and
there was bipartisan legislation led by
absolutely senator Lankford from
Oklahoma we need to make sure that you
have those paper trails and there is an
audit system in place there is a ranking
member on the Intel committee we got to
ask you about the New York Times report
that there said that the president is
using his iPhone it's unsecured and that
the Russians and Chinese are listening
to that do you have any evidence that's
actually taking place
John I've not got direct evidence and
I'm going to be getting a update on that
shortly but what I do know is this if
it's if true in a world where
cybersecurity is one of our key areas
where we are vulnerable I believe still
as a nation this would be one more
example where the president basically is
it kind of ignoring the overall advice
the intelligent a who's gonna be giving
you that briefing I'll get that briefing
later today from a part of my job and
national security to make sure I get
these previews but not necessarily share
all the information all right we don't
mind you sharing I understand senator
very good to have you here today thank
you so thank you very much